lifestyle influencer megan thomas head
is here with some amazing products
for you and your busy family these
products will keep you looking and
feeling your best
while on the go right megan yes yes
i you know i'm kind of focusing on that
mom on the go because
you know right now with everything going
on mom's schedules have just exploded so
this is this is for y'all
and i want to start with the fact that
sometimes we need
an energy boost something to kind of
give us that boost
this right here is going to do it this
is celsius essential
energy drink it has been clinically
proven to accelerate metabolism
burn fat and calories and like i said
it's going to boost that energy so you
can keep checking out that to-do list
and it's going to do it without crash or
jitters which i really appreciate
there's seven essential vitamins in here
and none of the junk and you can easily
find it locally in las vegas at
smith's walmart nationally at target and
cvs so some really good stuff
now moving on to kind of a one-stop shop
for
some really great mom on the go ideas
this is yuzi
it's an e-commerce store it launched
back in november so it's relatively new
and i love that they encourage
creativity self-expression
inclusivity through style and fashion
and there's so many great things for
moms like scarves
tote bags there's masks there's also
this really cool
phone and mask sanitizer you can just
drop it in
sanitize you'd be good to go i love that
machine and i also want to mention
that ten percent of all their sales they
donate to americans for the arts so
you are looking good you are feeling
good you are doing good i love that so
much
it starts at only about eight dollars
and up for the product so it's really
uh really affordable uzi.com is where
you can find all that good stuff
now i want to say you know and if you
probably agree with me that
moms are basically the uh multitasking
geniuses of of all of us so i agree i
really love this product because it
helps with that we got to do all the
things all the time
this is from kia babies now kia babies
is a baby and maternity
lifestyle brand they focus on quality
products safety that type of thing
this is their kia babies baby carrier
wrap so it's super soft it's breathable
easy to use it's versatile and i love
that once it's on you've got the baby
strapped in
you don't have to feel like you have to
support the baby you can be hands-free
doing all the things you need to do
while you've got the baby on so it's
really going to take that
baby wearing up to the next level it
retails for only 26.99 and you can
easily find it at amazon
walmart.com and of course kiababies.com
now
the last thing i want to mention is the
fact that you know mom's on the go we
want to be comfortable
but that doesn't mean we can't be
stylish so i'm really excited about this
denim brand this is rev town and they're
kind of like the most comfortable jeans
you've ever put on your body it's kind
of like wearing sweatpants they're so
wonderful
they're a performance denim brand and i
want to compare them to some luxury
brands because they really are that
fabulous but you get them for a fraction
of the price they're only
79 a pair and they were developed and
designed by guys from under armour so
you're getting that performance and
comfort of an athletic pant
but in denim honestly i was taking notes
even for the non-moms on the go right
we're gonna find more information
everybody where can we find one for me
bourbon
bourbonblondblog.com and my instagram
megan tiffany perfect thank you so much
megan you're so fun